[موسيقى] كانت
هونغ كونغ على مفترق طرق
للثقافة الشرقية والغربية منذ
أيامها الاستعمارية عندما حكمت بريطانيا من عام
1841 إلى عام 1997
، حيث من السهل العثور على البرغر في
المدينة ، كما أن هذه البوتقة الثقافية
تمتد لتشمل الطب أيضًا
أوه جودفري تشان هو طبيب أورام للأطفال
في مستشفى كوين ماري في هونج كونج
بينما يمارس الطب الغربي ،
يمارس والده الطب الصيني التقليدي ،
والآن يجمع تشان بين الاثنين
ويجري بحثًا حول
القيمة السريرية للأدوية العشبية ،
وهذا مثل صندوق كنز منجم
اهتمامي الرئيسي  هو النظر في
الاستخدامات المختلفة
والمكونات النشطة للطفل
بشكل أساسي لأن المعلومات يتم
التخلي عنها
كثيرًا ، وغالبًا ما يتم وصف الطب الصيني التقليدي للمريض الذي يقوم
بعد ذلك بطهيها واستهلاكها في
شكلها الواسع ، وتستند الاستخدامات المختلفة للعشب في
الطب الصيني إلى  السجلات التاريخية
التي تمتد لآلاف السنين
ومع ذلك فإن ممارسة الطب الحديث متجذرة في
العيادة  يتم إنتاج الأدوية التجريبية
بكميات كبيرة ويتم وصفها لعلاج
حالات معينة بدلاً من
تخصيصها للفرد ،
ولكن في حين أن الاثنين يختلفان على نطاق واسع ، فإنهما
غالبًا ما يعالجان نفس المشاكل.يعزز الفم الجاف
الدورة الدموية من أجل التركيز على مدر للبول.
هو
خبير في الطب الصيني ويدرب
الأجيال الشابة على الاستمرار في هذه
الممارسة القديمة في زولا ، وهذا يشمل
تشخيص المرضى عن طريق
فحص لسانهم وفحص نبضهم
لاختلالات الطاقة في الجسم ، ثم
يعطي لاو لمرضاه علاجات عشبية مصنوعة حسب الطلب
إذا قبل عام  بالنسبة للغربيين ،
ربما تذهب إلى متجر معًا ،
فالبدلة كل يوم هي نفسها ، ولكن إذا كانت الصين
مثل الخياط الذي يصنع البدلة
الخامسة بشكل فردي ، فإن مجموعته من
الطب الشرقي والغربي في هونغ
كونغ مقبولة من قبل العديد من
سكانها كبارًا وصغارًا.
نعتقد أن المدرستين تكملان
بعضهما البعض عندما يتعلق الأمر بمعالجة
بعض الأمراض مثل السرطان
سأحضر إلى الفندق ، جورج ولدت من جديد
أب رغم أنني سأتبعك
تعرف ما الذي نهضت عليه كيندال ولكن
كل شيء ثرثرة أمي مرحبًا كأنه لا توجد فكرة
لا تجعل طفلتنا
هي مالون هي - حسنًا ، أعرف  إنه قادم من هناك
، لا أعرف أنه يُعتقد أن الجينسنغ
يعزز الطاقة ويقلل من التعب وهو
الآن شائع في كل من
الثقافات الشرقية والغربية يعالج السرطان
بالعلاج الكيميائي أو العلاج الإشعاعي
وغالبًا ما ينتج عن العلاج بعض
الآثار الجانبية
أحيانًا الأرق وأحيانًا الغثيان
والقيء  - الطب الصيني الذي نحن عليه ،
يمكنك الصلاة من أجل الطريق أو مساعدتهم على
الإمساك بهم ولكن عند الجمع بين
الاثنين ، من المهم التأكد من عدم
إلغاء بعضهم البعض ، كل ذلك يسبب ضررًا ، على
سبيل المثال بعض الأدوية الصينية
مثل فطر لينغ جي يمكن  تتدخل
سلبًا في العلاج الكيميائي ، لذلك من
الأفضل دائمًا التحقق من
الأطباء الذين
يمكن ولا يمكن أخذهم علينا أن نكون
حذرين للغاية لأنه من المزايا الأخرى التي
يمكننا التعامل معها أيضًا
هناك حاجة إلى مزيد من البحث ، ولكن
يتم تسخير نقاط القوة في كل تخصص بشكل
متزايد من كلا
الجانبين.
عملية الاستفادة ليس فقط في المنزل
يمكننا نشر هذه المعلومات إلى
البلد هونغ كونغ
حيث سيحاول مكان اجتماعات Le West أن يستخدمها نموذج البروتون
للعالم بأسره
[موسيقى]